there's a super populated manga and
anime character in Japan whose name is
Detective Conan there he is
that's real detective conan leizerman
detective conan is a man who's trapped
in a child's body and solves crimes
sound a little familiar I don't solve
crimes but I am a man trapped in a
child's body my name is Conan now I have
established that Detective Conan is
clearly a ripoff of yours truly
detective conan was created in 1994
that's a year after I went on the air to
instant international acclaim now get
this Detective Conan is so popular in
Japan that there's an actual City
Hoku eh that's been renamed Conan town
I'm not making this up a whole city
called Conan town get this Conan town
even named their train station and their
Airport after Detective Conan now
clearly you have to be a genius to see
someone's been making a lot of money off
the Conan name
wouldn't you agree Andy the aterna
absolutely it's an open-and-shut case
thank you very much
what asked you that you didn't go to any
graduate school I I'm actually I haven't
been listening
I know finally I've got a sidekick that
listens to me and he's only here for one
night well anyway so the other night I
reasonably asked Japan to pay me three
trillion yen because I thought that was
only fair this thing has made a lot of
money for a long time for 24 years plus
I asked the mayor of Conan town to
change the name of the town's most
popular coin laundry to American Conan's
fluff and fold which I thought was fair
small price small price and I asked him
to change the hair on their Detective
Conan statue to something a little more
iconic and recognizable around well the
plot thickens over the weekend the mayor
of Conan Town responded to my very
reasonable request with his own set of
demands he made a video let's take a
look from Oakland aka Conan time in
Japan I'm Mia
Matsumoto I have a few modest demands -
first I want my face next to President
Lincoln on Mount Rushmore
second I will buy all star on the
Hollywood Walk of Fame
Farren I want you to bring if it is such
an American hamburgers do you when you
come that's one for each soon Oh Conan
Tom be here or be square that guy
clearly I did not realize who I was
dealing with mayor Matsumoto I know
you're watching and I say this with all
respect you are a very shrewd negotiator
you got me I will fulfill all three of
your requests you wanted your face added
to Mount Rushmore but I'll do you one
better instead of sharing Rushmore with
four other people who wants that I got
you your very own mountain right here in
Burbank California check it out
[Applause]
he's emerging from the hillside amazing
yeah now trust me trust me mayor this is
an actual real window looking out on a
real mountain
isn't that right Andy it's Burbank all
right because I can keep an eye on my
wife all right very nice what do you say
other Andy is real right I'm absolutely
real spoken like a true lawyer next next
you asked me for a star on the Hollywood
Walk of Fame luckily for you I'm a
pretty big deal in this town and in show
business in general
I made one or two phone calls went right
to the top and I easily got you your
star on the Hollywood Walk of Fame
take a look
[Applause]
and finally you asked for 15,000
American hamburgers one for every
resident of Kona town the problem is mr.
mayor I don't know how everybody likes
them
some people like theirs medium rare some
like them well-done
so I'm did it so little early so so I'm
gonna ship you all the material you need
to make the burgers yourselves yes
mr. mayor that's right in one week's
time in exactly one week's time this
steer will be parachuted into Conant
town where you and your citizens can do
whatever you like to have perfect
American hamburgers let's get the
shipping label on that steer right now
let's get them ready to go very nice
mayor Matsumoto I've met all of your
demands now it's time for me to call
your bluff I want my three trillion yen
so here's what's gonna happen and this
is real next week I am flying to Japan
and coming to Conan town to collect my
money mr. mayor I'll be square
[Applause]
you